- Welcome back y'all.
Our next guest is a legendary chef
with more than a dozen
restaurants to his name.
He's also a bestselling
author, TV personality,
and the founder of World Central Kitchen.
His newest book is a graphic novel
about World Central Kitchen
called "Feeding Dangerously."
Let's welcome everybody, Chef Jose Andres.
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music playing)
- Yes, lay down.
(audience laughing)
So we're gonna start with your childhood.
No, I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding.
No, I heard, wait,
I love your energy by the way.
And I'm not kidding,
I bawled like getting
ready for this interview
'cause you're an amazing human.
You're an incredible human.
(audience cheering)
You are.
Like, it's like,
it's really amazing, like what you do.
I knew about the restaurants,
I knew all that stuff.
I didn't know all about
the humanitarian stuff.
You're an incredible man.
- Well, ask my wife.
She may have a different opinion.
(all laughing)
We've been almost 30 years married
and she says that technically she's been
married to me 60 years.
I don't know.
- [Kelly] It feels more.
It feels like more.
- Yeah, ask my daughters,
I don't think they will have
the same opinion of you.
(all laughing)
- That's okay.
Family is supposed to keep it real.
- Yeah, "Daddy don't speak English,
nobody can understand you.
We will translate for you."
This type of daughters.
(all laughing)
So yeah, I guess I'm a good human being.
- This type of daughters.
I like, wait, wait,
so in speaking of your daughter,
you have a thing in your
household like cooking paella
is like a very dangerous thing.
What and why?
What?
- Yeah.
- What happened?
- I think this is fake news, people.
This is something is going around.
- No, I hear it's about fire.
- Okay.
- All right,
I am a dad.
- [Kelly] Check.
- That I'm a cook.
That I believe my daughters
to be out of danger's way.
I will have them better prepared for life
if I teach them from
early on about the dangers
of the wall,
not putting them behind walls.
(all laughing)
So yes,
I let my daughters use knives with barely
they were two years old
and cook with open fire.
And sometimes the fires I make at home,
they can be very big cooking the paella.
And my,
and the fire is bigger than my daughters.
(audience laughing)
And the fire is a really big fire.
And when you have little
daughters and big fire,
and you are teaching your
daughter how to make the paella,
the fire sometimes is nice.
The fire wants to help you,
wants to kiss you,
because fire is a good person
if you treat it with respect.
And I think the fire
wanted us to give kind
of little kiss to my daughter's eyebrows.
(audience laughing)
And was a little, you know,
smelly, a little bit.
My daughters were overdoing it,
"Daddy, you burn me."
"I didn't burn you.
It was the fire."
- It was the fire.
I said, "Don't tell anything to mommy.
Please don't."
Just let's keep it.
I mean, yeah,
when I forgot one of my daughters,
yeah in the supermarket,
but I came back.
(all laughing)
I got, hey-
- "But I came back."
- Hey, I didn't have salt
and it was very important.
I was baking and missing salt
and my daughter,
"Yeah, you got the salt,
but what about me?"
So yeah, but between the fire and that,
I don't think even-
- Father of the year, yeah.
- Yeah, father of the year, yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
That looked cool too,
the thing you were cooking it in.
That was really cool.
We showed the video of
that big black thing.
That was cool.
- A paella pan.
- That is what, no,
but what's the thing underneath of it?
Was it connected?
- Yeah, it's like,
it's like,
I don't know.
- Look, I'm gonna be real with you.
I make like nothing.
So like, I'm not a cook.
- What?
- So I've never seen
yeah, yeah.
No.
- You're not a cook.
- No.
And I am, this is not fair 'cause-
- You don't sing when you cook?
- No, yeah, that's-
- You don't cook when you-
- I got the one talent, man.
Yeah, that's it.
(audience laughing)
It's the one.
- I don't think
she has one talent.
I think she has many, many talents.
- I can't even make eggs.
(audience cheering)
I can't even make eggs.
- All right, people of America,
The Kelly and Jose Cooking show.
- Yeah.
- She teaches.
- I make paella.
- She teaches me to sing
and I teach her to cook,
bingo.
(audience cheering)
- As long as no one,
okay, I'll do that.
As long as no one's eating my food.
No wait, but speaking of food,
like my, okay, this is a good segue.
My dogs will not even eat my food.
So you have,
you have made a pet food,
which would, they would love.
So it's called Real Mesa?
- Man, your pronunciation
is unbelievable.
- Real Mesa.
Thank you.
- Real, okay.
- Thank you, Real.
- Okay, so yeah,
I have this, I got this line that,
just we put out of amazing dog food.
When I was young, my father, my mother,
we had the home, a German shepherd.
- Mm.
- My father will cook for us
and would cook for the dog.
I think he put more love in cooking
for the dog he did for us.
- Yeah, poor y'all.
- And I was with friends.
He have a lot of experience
in the pet business
and they said, "Jose,
why you don't do just pet food
that celebrates your
Latino Spanish heritage?"
And I thought it was a great idea,
because when you're eating with friends,
good ideas always come.
And then I realized that even
in the worst moments of humanity,
people sometimes will put
themselves in dangers.
I've seen it in Ukraine.
I've seen it in so many other parts,
that a pet in a way,
is as part of the family,
and will be people not
leaving in their homes,
even if sometimes it's not as smart,
because they can be in danger.
But for them,
if they cannot take the dogs with them,
they will stay next to them.
So this is this 360 degree story of
yes, everybody is family,
even our pets are family.
So it's great that Real Mesa,
a percentage of the profits
that hopefully be successful
and will have profits are always gonna go,
in this case,
to support my NGO World Central Kitchen.
That this is a way that if
you take care of every family,
you know the families are
also taking care of their pet.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
I wanna talk about World Central Kitchen.
This is what had me just bawling,
learning all this about you.
This is at the most devastating
moments in people's lives,
you come in and you feed these people.
Don't even,
nobody even really thinks about that.
I don't think that's not the
first thing at the forefront
of their minds.
So what got you into this?
- Well, what got me into
this is to understand
that sometimes in emergencies,
food and water was an afterthought.
And that cooks like me,
that we feed the few,
we had the same power to feed the many,
and especially if we all come together.
It's restaurants everywhere.
Every arena has food stands,
it's food trucks,
it's catering companies.
And I thought, oh my God,
I watched Katrina,
how we had tens of thousands
of Americans almost forgotten
in the Superdome,
where actually it was very easy
to take care of them.
For days,
they didn't receive foot and water.
So I thought, what if,
so I didn't do anything in Katrina.
I stayed in the comfort of my home.
When Haiti happened, 2010,
I took a plane,
the big earthquake that
killed hundreds of thousands
of Haitians in Port-au-Prince.
I went and I began doing what I know,
learning.
And I began feeding
people without realizing.
We've been now in every single hurricane,
earthquake, volcano,
and lately also in conflicts.
In Ukraine alone,
in the last two years,
we've done more than 240
million meals inside Ukraine.
- [Kelly] Wow.
(audience cheering)
- Unfortunately, right
now we're in Armenia,
we're in Lebanon,
we are in Israel doing more
than 240,000 hundred meals already.
We are also inside Gaza, 240,000 meals.
Also hot and a million meals
so people can cook themselves,
because we already had food inside Gaza.
At the end,
what we are trying to send
a message is that food
and water is a universal human right.
We believe in longer tables
and bringing people together.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah.
It's also, the beauty of it,
is obviously we need food and water.
But the beauty of it too is that they're,
you're not forgotten.
Like people are not forgetting you.
Like to have the impact of that,
of them walking up and everything is just,
their life has been devastated
and somebody cooking a warm meal for them,
that's, that transforms hearts.
- It's such an important message,
because people don't want our pity,
they want our respect.
- Hmm.
- Well, what Central
Kitchen does is comes,
but we allow every single
local that wants to help
and volunteer to join us.
It's not like we make them better.
They make us better,
because who is better than the locals
that know their communities?
That's why in the case of Ukraine,
we went from two people,
World Central Kitchen,
to a team of more than 550 restaurants
and 5,000 team members distributing
food all across Ukraine.
You see,
we build teams.
- The domino effect.
- Everybody wants to help in
the worst moments of humanity,
the best of humanity shows up
and the best.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah, I agree with that.
Well, I wanna talk about this,
because you have a new graphic novel,
it's "Feeding Dangerously."
So I didn't,
I didn't know this about you,
but you're like really into like comics,
graphic novels, all that, right?
- Manga, I love.
- You look 10 years old right now.
Look at you're.
(audience laughing)
You, I love it.
I love it.
So this is important to you.
- So you know,
the amazing social media
that you receive now,
messages and you can talk to everybody.
It's Steve Orlando.
I mean Steve Orlando is like
LeBron James, Jordan, Messi
of comic books.
And he text me like,
"Hey dude,
I wanna tell the story
of World Centra Kitchen."
I'm like, "Okay cool."
And here we are four, five years later,
which tells the story of the beginnings
of World Central Kitchen.
But there you're gonna see
stories of the many men
and women that did the incredible,
happen under very difficult circumstances.
So you're gonna see me
cooking paella with my dad,
because he was a very
important early influence.
You're gonna see us then cooking paella
in the middle of Puerto Rico,
when we fed 4 million people
after Maria, Category 5 hurricane,
destroyed the entire island.
You're gonna see many of the key moments
that made World Central
Kitchen what it is today.
We're still learning.
We're still a very young organization,
but with this book, with this comic,
I want to tell the story
of what we're doing,
so more people can join us.
More people can be
empowered to do what we do
and then one day we can say,
we'll never have hunger
again ever in the world.
If we come together,
we can solve the big problems
that humanity is facing.
- Absolutely.
- This is a fun way
to tell that story.
- Yeah.
A very cool way to do it.
I'm gonna hold it up,
'cause I love it.
It's so, people are so talented.
Like it's incredible to me.
But everybody,
for more details on World Central Kitchen,
check out our Instagram story.
Alright, we are back,
and I'm hanging out with Chef Jose Andres,
(audience cheering)
and our next guest are
super stoked to meet him.
In fact,
he's the actual inspiration
behind their efforts
to keep people in their community fed.
They've rallied fellow high
schoolers to come together
to start a program similar
to World Central Kitchen
on a local level.
From Kitchens for Change,
everybody say hello to Elias and Audrey.
(audience cheering)
So meet Chef Jose.
(hands slapping)
So, okay, I'm gonna ask y'all like,
explain Kitchens for Change.
Where did this come from?
And the inspiration.
- At its core,
Kitchens for Change is
really about high schoolers
coming together and
trying to combat the issue
of food insecurity in our local community.
And really, we found our,
it's the legs for this organization.
It was me and my mother.
We were sitting there and we saw,
you know, post pandemic,
how rampant the issue of food insecurity
was in our local community.
And we had seen Jose Andres
and the amazing work he did
with World Central Kitchen.
And we thought to ourselves,
you know, we can do a spinoff of this
in our local community and
really make a great impact.
- Yeah, and both Elias and I's families
are in the restaurant business.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- So we got to thinking,
how can we use the resources
we have with our restaurants
to get students involved in
tackling food insecurities
within our community?
And to our surprise,
we had over a hundred students willing
to jump on board with our mission.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So we used our restaurant's kitchens
after hours to get students in there,
mentored by local chefs.
And we started cooking
for areas in our community
that were facing food insecurity.
And to this day,
we're not just a club on campus,
but we're an actual nonprofit organization
with multiple chapters.
(audience cheering)
- That's so incredible.
So what have you learned?
Like, because I love one thing you said,
you said your organization, like,
"We still have more to learn."
And I think any
organization that knows that
is the organization to get behind,
because to stop learning is death,
I think of anything,
you know of a human,
of an organization or whatnot.
So what do you think that you've learned
through World Central Kitchen?
- What I learned is that
very often we are taught
that we always need to follow a plan.
What did we learn during the pandemic?
That very often things
never go as planned.
- What happens if you
embrace the complexity
of the moment and you train your family,
your businesses,
the people around you to adapt?
- Hmm.
- Adaptation wins
the day over planning,
what these two amazing
individuals they've done.
They adapted to the situation,
they saw what they had around them,
and they did the most
they could with what was
at their disposal,
to use their family businesses,
restaurants, after hours,
used to feed the local community need.
It's used a magical,
simple, powerful idea.
It's people like them, that yes,
we can change America.
We can improve America.
We can change the world.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
I agree, yeah.
(audience cheering)
Well, Elias's mama, Mohini,
is in the audience and
she's a culinary teacher
at his high school
and helps advise Kitchens for Change.
So Mohini, oh my gosh.
I mean, you've gotta be so proud.
- Yes, I am.
I am so proud of Audrey and Elias.
Ever since Elias was born, I,
as a gut level, as a mom,
I knew he was destined
for something great.
And I think they both are.
And whatever they do in their life,
I just want them to always
remember this time in their life
and that passion and what
food means for people,
and that's where you hit the core.
And Chef Jose Andres,
you are an epitome of
success for students,
for chefs, for people like us.
You've taken something and
you've given back to this world
and it's everything that's
good about this world.
Thank you.
- You're the best.
And she gave me amazing Indian spices.
- [Kelly] Oh she did?
- I cannot wait to get in my kitchen
and start cooking with those.
- Oh, well our friends, this
is for Eliza and Audrey.
Our friends at Conagra believe everybody
deserves consistent
access to nutritious food
and they love the work that you're doing
at Kitchens for Change,
so they are donating $10,000 to help out.
- No way!
- Woo!
- Yes.
It's incredible.
- Thank you so much.
- Absolutely.
- Absolutely, thank y'all
so much for joining us.
We're gonna be right back, everybody.